[Musique]
oh
aucune règle
la pub flic la plus politique la plus
personne
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
qu'on a vécu là bas
tu sais rien des quartiers nord
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pas de stylo pas de radio pas de
journaux pas de discussions politiques
les visites ont lieu une fois par mois à
rester au lit alors que marc locsta je
pourrais facilement m'y habituer vous
êtes le mandela blanc c'est lui qui se
blesse le plus d'illusions quoi qu'il
arrive dans ce tribunal
pourtant on a entendu parler de vous
deux vous avez pris combien huit ans
pour moi eidos pour lui mais on n'a pas
l'intention de rester si longtemps ce
mur fait six mètres de haut il ya des
barbelés tout autour de la cour des
gardes armés jusqu'aux dents de notre
retour en cellule jusqu'à l'aube des
tunnels
quelle que soit la direction et vous
ramènerai tous jusqu'à la prison tout le
monde arrive ici en s'imaginant pouvoir
se faire la belle la semaine suivante où
il ya un début à tout c'est exactement
mon affiche où tu crois que tu vas
pouvoir fabriquer une clé avec un crayon
a bien su le faire en moi c'est
complètement dingue
donc tout ce qu'on a à faire c'est
fabriqué une clé extrêmement complexe et
faire en sorte qu'elle atteigne la
serrure situé de l'autre côté de la
porte claret de 8 cm d'épaisseur alors
qu'on n'y absolument galaxy
j'adore cette idée en cas d'échec
vous prendrez 25 ans si vous avez de la
chance ou une balle dans la tête si vous
en avez pas arrêter tout
c'est quoi cette chose
dix ans lève toi tu te penches comtois
[Musique]
votre plan tout entier voué à l'échec
n'abandonnerai jamais
il a rien fait pour mériter ça
on est des prisonniers d'opinion c'est
pas la même chose pour nous nous on est
des prisonniers de guerre
c'est quoi tous les matins
et c'est cette méprise et nous c'est
avec ça qu'on va lutter ils sont à moi
accrochez vous à cette colère elle vous
rappelle qu'il existe un autre monde
en dehors d'ici
[Musique]
jce
et ta mère wen
j'étais dans un avion papa maman t'es
pas là
alors quoi pas le vol s'est bien passé
on s'en fout tu m'a demandé de venir te
chercher
tu t'en souviens n'aurais jamais demandé
sa tête
à part tu sais que maman d'état là
j'ai oublié parce que tu es trop vieux
tu ressembles à une conversion
il savait que tu étais [ __ ] de l'armée je
ne savais pas vraiment
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
attac mois tant que tueur et mais je ne
rentre plus dans ton jeu
quand un type de montage se dit qu'ils
enrichissent et c'est qu'il l'a déjà
faire tu crois qu'on ne voit pas venir
[Musique]
c'est vraiment un gros con toi qu'une
pauvre pédales
j'ai certes des papas
[Musique]
pradines mais enfin
on a parlé de moi qu'est ce que tu as
dit vous êtes le diable
c'était vrai à avoue qu'elle est bonne
le bonne tous les gangs de los angeles
doivent payer leurs taxes et à mon
réveil cité à courre cambriole une borne
vol de l'argent est amer aucune excuse
on ne va pas mettre sa dot au robot
vous avez l'air de deux monstres
allez en enfer twem et chanter avec
sarah tu te souviens de la fois aussi
m'a refilé 3 mds différents rien rires
plata femmes les enfants touche-à-tout
puissance et terrorisé le troupeau c'est
ça ma fonction
dieu me permet de traverser les ténèbres
et de revenir à la lumière quand tu m'as
rencontre qu'est ce qui te plaît on
m'avait dit que c'était un grand méchant
games perds tu taxe 43 gangs de rue
différence a fait des milliers de gens
de la sous culture la plus violente de
los angeles
il manque de l'argent qui es tu je suis
l'avenir et toi le passé
j'étais enfin tu veux les racheter
crois pas qu'ils aient du sens il veut
arracher le coeur le pass joindre à lui
dit s'enfuir qu'est ce qui reste
j'ai sur moi taux k league 3 81 38 et à
25,4 chauffeur dans le kop est un bien
commun qu'est ce que tu veux plus je
suis
[Musique]
imposant pris les enfants tu prêt à tout
sacrifier pour toi bien du n'était pas
si dur que ça
no kill
allez hop ta gueule il va faire sauter
la cervelle et je veux pas ça oui moi je
veux sort la voiture approche à
l'imposition commissaire il faut le
prendre en flag rugby tel qu'ils
trouvent ryan on habite dans la même
cité et qu'est ce qu'ils font ce qu ont
par contre tu veux pas rester là parce
qu'on est sur une grosse intervention là
ça risque de tirer dans tous les sens tu
ferais mieux de partir
[Musique]
il vous reste très peu de temps à vivre
très peu de temps c'est à dire 30 jours
max
[Musique]
ça nous fera 35 euros s'il vous plaît
je veux reprendre l'enquêté sur leurs
ardeurs j'en ai déjà une piste à 13,10 à
l'horizon
[Musique]
encore 2 à peu près
m
beaucoup de jeunes
via un tournoi de danse organisée à kiev
le gagnant remportera 30000 euros sa
terrasse en opération études en sera
encore mieux qu'avant
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le père tendue elle quittera
définitivement le concours
tiens
au xiii ne vient pas est ce qu'ils se
seraient des filets non parce que je
vais gagner de toute façon salut toi
petit chouchou mais il y à une plainte
contre lui sa place est derrière les
barreaux
dis moi qu'est ce que tu aurais à
m'offrir toit des rollers c'est quoi
l'amour pour toi juste bon pour les
contes de fées elle rêve d'un prince
laissons le danser
[Musique]
si vous êtes là sans doute vous avez été
sélectionné
[Musique]
quant au free ni la durée
je fais ça parce que je t'aime
il va danser
derrick mal à l'est du district est
aussi j'ai fait ce que j'ai à faire
tu parles comme un vrai soldat
puis certains tu reconnais son vieil ami
le vendeur comment l'oublier
il m'a tiré dans le dos mais depuis deux
ans ils sèment la terreur partout autour
du globe
[Musique]
une semaine le vendeur a volé du
matériel technologique avec ça nous
allons son seul mandat
j'ai besoin de toi est en équipe sur ce
coup là vous fait à ma manière et vous
posez pas de questions jean-marc
d'accord je suis avec toi
j'aime pas cet endroit patron le fauteur
il s'en vient c'est ça
si vous voulez sur vire nous allons
devoir collaborer
[Musique]
n'oubliez pas où les sommes nécessaires
et tous les avantages star et se sert de
ma fille
sandra moi tu as des enfants mais leur
ramène plus tôt ma petite fille allons-y
montre-toi montre toi où que tu sois
c'est vraiment pas quand il est temps de
rendre les armes les barbes toi
on peut compter sur moi ce drame
[Musique]
la magie à la fois sublime et puissante
et le lien qui unifie notre long passé
ce lien que nous partageons tous et
l'héritage de poudlard
[Applaudissements]
temps aujourd'hui de bâtir votre propre
histoire
ton ce lieu mythique
et peut-être même de façonner le futur
duo
des 106
chaque couloir chaque portrait chaque
pierre de ce château raconte l'histoire
des censiés et des sorcières qui étaient
là ah bon ici vous vous ferez des amis
pour la vie et développerez vos
compétences en magie dans les salles de
classe des professeurs les plus
talentueux tandis que vous entamerez
votre aventure à poudlard concoctant des
pensions dont temps des animaux
fantastiques
des pratiquants de sort
plus faste s'ouvrira au delà de ces
deux rempli de dangers que vous nous
imaginez un savoir anciens disparus
depuis fort longtemps de ce monde
son talon étrange et mystérieux que vous
possédez et peut-être la clé qui vous
permettra de débloquer ce pouvoir en
dormant
votre potentiel
[Musique]
limité
mais quelle forme prendra cours
[Musique]
aventure qui vous attend
révélera quels sont vos véritables
valeurs
[Musique]
les choix que vous ferez
miron l'héritage
de poudlard